yeah I went to welcoming into this video
playing P way pray P way okay so what is
he going to play against my other kinds
really something else and deform Wow
okay
yeah probably just go back no particular
reason to try anything fancy so what's
going on here
I don't have many squares iam in 586 or
something hey I should play d5
nice a success is a move I mean a six no
30 goes a six okay I can just recapture
and probably wait 96 set a pawn on e5
and I cannot take it I think so let's
develop yeah just back to f6 I guess
yeah I mean that was a bit strange what
Dwight did but it's so reasonably okay I
mean you can just develop normally now
92 wind C 3 please moves like that
possible so probably lights is fixin
well takes Bishop b5 is kind of annoying
them cut Queen b6 down
yeah it should it should be okay place
that immediately interesting
okay so Queen to b6 nano d5 is a threat
again
yeah I can go Bishop this 7-eleven so
good we had everything
hope I'm not blundering stuff yeah can
happen to boots builder and click on
stantly place for four tactics IAM
looking for tricks ok if I just take
here
I will check soups
I mean d5 I have 95 it's not
if f95 Bishop e6 takes take takes on v6
I think it works for the moment I'd
still very tricky
[Music]
d 595 doesn't work and I take can take
this eclectic f3 take b6 at the end he
cannot take on b7 because of okay so d5
doesn't work I still don't like this
some this some kind of unresolved
situation here anyway to get this
I mean Catholic would be nice so we
still play the jumping camp maybe you
can move the Queen but I thought your
screen c7 must be okay then maybe Queen
e2 for example like it takes ideas God
might be five again yep so am I only
have Queen c7 I guess takes them
interesting okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay yeah I can take and just which 95
let's see four okay I wanted to cancel
anyway yeah this is okay that must be
okay for black bit down on the clock so
night will come to c6
I'm warning you I know
interesting I would like to to take
something with this night and I just
check interesting now I might might
really attack it with night be to check
check
[Music]
check you get a couple of seconds
[Music]
check check check is wrong now really
chain not to win this ending after
defending the whole time and anyway it
was tricking was really tricky the the
whole opening stage was so so weird yeah
I had spent too much time there okay so
have a look at them yeah I don't think I
can do anything fancy and maybe he
success better I don't know still did
not want to yeah give up this auction
later well okay but this is certainly
okay it can never be really bad from
like so our queen bee three years doing
that ah double attack
okay so then I have to go a 6m probably
better then da it's not probably better
it is better now just blocking the
diagonal Queen b3 was winning them and
here this is extremely critical okay it
seems he can take this yeah I wasn't I
wasn't really sure here okay so this
does work okay okay okay
and good porn Kim yeah now I'm kind of
kick I'm okay again okay so I can
actually take yeah I wasn't sure I was
c4 and I have cause I can take because I
still have this thread so that wins to
win swings completely so I just take the
end when okay it looks a little bit more
precise vADM okay I mean I had to
somehow increase the speed yeah because
of the earlier times and and I mean I
got into this nice ending he somehow
carefully didn't cover the pawns yeah
okay I did manage spend too much time
okay guys thanks for watching